great so now we are sitting down with
Sonny Jane from Sun genomics and we are
gonna talk about the importance of the
microbiome and what we can better
understand about it so your company
actually takes a sample from humans of
their stool and then analyzes so many
different things about it teach us about
it
yeah we're now understanding just how
much of ourselves is actually microbial
and so before we would always study our
human DNA trying to ameliorate what are
the one of the reasons for these disease
conditions and in the last five to ten
years we now understand that there's
this whole new group of cells living
inside of us called the microbiome that
is related to all these disease
conditions and so we want to empower
customers to be able to see what's going
on inside of them were we're the x-ray a
little bit but we're also providing the
treatment as well so then you mentioned
that there's actually a decent amount of
these disease indicators that are
actually occur in our microbiome so by
microbiome we're talking about our gut
our GI tract the whole thing but mostly
what goes on after our stomach that's
right yeah so once you're entering into
your small intestine and then you also
have your large colon those two
components of your of your gut is where
most of your microbial population will
live that includes bacteria yeast fungi
viruses and parasites Dam so actually
most often when you have a viral
infection or a viral bacteria that's
happening to you that's causing you to
be a little sick it's being housed down
there well sometimes they can be okay
but it could also be respite or espera
Tori for which there also is benefit in
having good stuff going on down here to
protect anything happening you know in
the lungs as well so so there we're kind
of inter connected more than we thought
and bacterial communities are very
interconnected and
just knowing your composition is the
beginning and we're providing
interpretation on that so we actually
help people realize real benefits from
that information and the first thing
that we're providing back is a probiotic
ok so ok so then you analyze my stool
and then you provide me with a probiotic
that you think is going to best help my
microbiome that's right so we can
analyze all the species level organisms
in your gut biome and you were listing
fungi and fungi bacteria viruses phages
any other parasites as well many people
many of our customers travel and
different areas of the world and you
never know when you might pick something
up and it can stay inside of us many of
these these organisms can be what they
call opportunistic pathogens it just
kind of live inside of our guts for
months years sometimes and we've been
going about life just managing around
them and now we can actually ID them and
take steps to fix it
and live healthier lives ok and so
that's what you're saying you're saying
I need them ok so then how do you guys
how does one even take a stool sample
and ID what we're discussing all these
different organisms so that's one of the
key innovations that we have at Sun
genomics we're utilizing something
called next-generation sequencing or NGS
and that is enabling the science around
microbiome analysis and identification
so we can actually look at the DNA level
which is the most stable sort of
molecular level component of your gut
like DNA is preserved in you know
ancient mummies and and things that's
just really stable right so if it's in
your gut and we detect it we can be
pretty sure it's there and by that
analysis we're actually able to ID
things from what they call a
bioinformatics pipeline and that's a
software component to what we do that
takes all those DNA base pairs that a CG
that will read out and it Maps it back
to a database of information that we
house ok so then so then ok so we're
we're taking a sample we're analyzing it
and then we're seeing that there are
certain compositions of these different
IDs that you're you're starting to see
and then then how D what is considered a
balanced microbiome or one ideal
microbiome and it defers from person to
person yeah it absolutely does so
there's there is no ideal microbiome to
that we know today but what we do know
is sort of the flip when there are bad
things going on so this is your main
thing
yeah there's when there's bad stuff then
you deliver the probiotic yeah and many
of us can benefit from probiotics even
if there isn't something there let's say
Olympic athletes for instance when
they're in intense training regimens
yeah if they have the right formulas of
probiotics they've shown that you can
reduce the number occurrences of
illnesses over intense training period
huge for athletes right now instead of
being sick and out three days they train
the whole season and that helps their
performance right okay so not only
individuals that have anything bad but
individuals just seeking to be better
right what would be one of the
probiotics they give me an example of
analyzing a stool and seeing that
there's something that you can assist
with and then what is the probiotic that
you would deliver so a really common one
is a food allergy like a lactose
intolerant individual you can look at
the microbiome profile and the first
thing we look at is kind of an itch off
of that just what probiotics do you
currently have probiotics are good
organisms providing what they call
commensal benefit to our gut system
they're good microbes essentially right
and we can ID those see where you are
today that's your baseline and then
think about if that's a limiting factor
for enabling lactose digestion which is
the issue with lactose intolerant
individuals so we now understand that
there's a specific organism black toe
bacillus acidophilus streptococcus
thermophilus maybe lack of a
SOLAS lactis as well I mean there's key
organisms these things that we don't
even barely understand yeah it's it's
just the eye opening field that has
grown tremendously over the last two to
three years they've been like I think
easily fifteen thousand publications
around got science and the microbiome in
the last two years wall fifteen thousand
two thousand yeah and that's that was a
signal to us right that was like there's
enough body of science here to help
people with their gut problems at this
stage and now we are I'm learning how to
pronounce these names of organisms and
there's still some I can't pronounce but
Bifidobacterium you know infant s is
really important for mothers that are
nursing Bifidobacterium breve can be
really important for a different
paradigm of nutrition that you're in a
different stage and so knowing what each
species does is critically important to
be able to provide the right match for
your gut and that's how we're able to do
it so lactose intolerant we can look at
your profile we see that you may be
missing one or two or maybe three of the
key strains that help people digest
lactose provide the organisms that
release lactose naturally in your body
these are natural occurring organisms
and have them going through your system
now when lactose comes through it can
digest it
we used to provide that on dairy itself
we used to provide it in the cheese or
these are strains that are in the milk
itself yeah but the problem is you're
drinking that it's still got to go to
your your stomach is going to kill it
from the acid right so it's got to make
it through to your intestines and that's
where the lactose gets absorbed and
that's why people are these more
probiotics don't get killed by the
stomach acid that's right so we we
developed around that with the with the
capsule making sure that at a low pH
which is acidic in our in our stomachs
the capsule won't open and then as soon
as it crosses into the small intestine
the pH rises to like five and a half and
then the capsule begins to dissolve so
the full load of the
area and the microbes are the providers
million people I love it love it thank
you people that are I'm so grateful to
have all of you here and pitching and
learning from all of you this is this is
especially something so fascinating to
be able to engineer it past that stomach
acid and to be able to give good
probiotics into the body especially when
you're analyzing yourself and your you
have some deficiencies in certain
aspects and this is this is really good
stuff is there something else that's
important maybe you tell us about
exactly where you're at and the process
how many people are taking your are you
taking the stool samples from right now
well right now we're just under a
thousand subscribers we've seen great
great traction we believe we'll get to
our goal by the end of the year to be
just north of that and we we've seen an
amazing month over month growth from
being part of the accelerator in Dubai
oh and then just adoption as more people
realize this is an option I mean I think
today a lot of people because we're a
small start-up may not know this product
exists and so their only option is to go
to the store and one of the things that
that really piqued my interest was
there's actual recommendations when you
like search the web for how should I
choose a probiotic some of the
recommendations are try one and if it
doesn't work try another and and we want
to change that we want to make it so try
one this worked for you look at your
benefits at retest and you could
actually see how it worked and then
stack upon it what do you want to do
next you okay we solved for your
inflammation that was going on yeah but
now you want to do something related to
increasing absorption because you're
taking some minerals or supplements so
let's build a formula for that next
three months yeah and just keep stacking
things to make our microbiomes better
over time do you think this would help
the hundred thousand plus people that
have Crohn's and other bowel
inflammatory issues
I think without question people are
studying intensely too as far as the the
profiles that Crohn's patients or IBD
patients have we're very close to a
diagnostic level on IBD with these
microbes in our gut great meaning the
body of science is very close and we're
excited for that moment because
hopefully we can provide some sections
as well so great yeah for all the people
that really need it I feel like so so
the come there's so many competitors
right but you like you biome and volume
these companies they're they're not
close those don't close the loop they
don't provide you with a probiotic at
the end they just give you the analysis
is the thing yeah one of the things that
we set out early to do was not be an
information only company yeah we want to
actually interpret on the information
provide actionable results right and and
actually have a dietary supplement that
you take because now you can manage it
yourself and you can see the change
yourself on retest and that's an
empowerment to our customer base yes
exactly and and the behavior change we
know has exit I mean go to the doctor
and you're unhealthy or something and
the doctor is gonna say eat better and
exercise more right which that's what
you mostly get when you just have
information right and we want to say yes
you should eat better and exercise more
but here also take this pill to
jumpstart you and to enable the good
microbes to get into your into your
flora so that you can have some
protection but you can also make some
changes to the quality of your
microbiome and from there what we've
seen is our customers see it as the
lifestyle change right it's as part of
their supplement procedure in the
morning whether it be vitamins and
probiotics you know you take that as a
conscious decision to do it and so then
when you go to eat breakfast you're
gonna be healthier when you go to have
lunch you might not opt for the
cheeseburger and go for the green beans
and grilled chicken or something
so we've seen that change in our
customer base and I think that's great
that people are empowered that way this
is great sunny because there's something
else about about something that you
think would be good to talk about well
one thing we we've talked about food
allergies a little bit and and some of
the chronic conditions also one thing
that is really sort of more near and
dear to why we started Sun genomics is
because my son had gastrointestinal
issues as an infant and what we're now
understand is that in the first thousand
days of life that's when you're early
microbiota gets seated and it stays with
you for a long period of time unless you
have an antibiotic issue or some other
things too to deplete it and what
studies are showing is that if the right
organisms are not seated or some of the
bad organisms are seated then you're at
risk for asthma allergies diabetes yeah
all these conditions and there just
hasn't been inferred there's been
scientific literature talking about it
but there hasn't been a solution and we
want to we want to help people with that
as much as possible as well so that a
parent such as myself doesn't have to
feel scared and blindly go into the
development of their child going well I
hope is microbiome is good yeah and they
can check it know they can see how it is
and make their own decision for what
what to implement hell yes yeah thank
you so much Sonny Thank You Roger
yeah I'm really inspired by what you
guys are doing hopefully maybe I can
help make some connections in the space
so we can really all work on together on
analyzing and then providing the good
provider
for us yeah we'd appreciate that thanks
so much for your time thank you